[Music]
um hi everyone
um my name is tyler smith i am the
associate director of financial aid
uh here at the gsb and today i am joined
by my colleague liz
hi everyone good morning from northern
california i'm elizabeth yamas
i'm currently serving as the interim
director of financial aid
um and i've been with the gsb for about
three years and in financial aid for 16
years
so quite a bit of time excited to be
here
thanks liz um so today liz and i are
going to just be walking through some
common questions we get here in the
financial aid office
from students from prospective students
and just kind of go over them and use
this opportunity to
kind of cover these topics and also we
have the q a section as well
we're joined by two of our financial aid
counselors ryan and yasmin
they'll be in there to answer any
questions um that you might want to type
in as well
and towards the end too we'll leave some
time for liz and i
to uh to answer some of those questions
live um
in front of all of you as well but let's
go ahead and kind of like get started
uh with some like the the first and
biggest questions so
so liz um as these prospective students
you know
they're beginning to start their
research into their mba and
they're finding out that there's many
different avenues that can go down and
there's many different ways schools do
financial aid
uh summer merit-based summer merit hand
need-based uh and the gsb is purely
need-based
so i'd love to hear from you why the gsb
is need-based and what's the philosophy
behind that
yeah and and so everyone is on the same
page just to make sure
they're the difference between merit and
need essentially the
merit financial aid is awarded at the
discretion of the institution
based on your individual achievements or
other attributes of how they want to
award and
a need-based system uh essentially is
based off the need of the individual and
that's usually a financial need
um of the individual and so the gsb is a
need-based institution and there was
lots of reasons why we went to need base
but we did have three guiding principles
that we wanted to achieve with whatever
financial aid system that we
um implemented and so the first one was
excellence no matter what we chose
we still wanted to deliver the best
class possible right an excellent
diverse class the next one was access
so the student whoever you know receives
financial aid
or is coming to the gsb has this can
have the same experience
um as anyone else so there's a access to
the educational experience
uh and then overwhelmingly when we
reached out to community members like
students
uh and staff and faculty and alumni
the idea of fairness was really
important to the gsb
everyone everyone who's admitted has
worked so
hard to get into the gsb that they
should have the same
opportunity for aid and there's a fair
and transparent
process and so when we boiled all that
up it really
overwhelmingly was a need-based system
and although merit is great the
need-based system really serves the
the mission and the purpose of the gsb
um and then
you know as just a side note what we
also loved about a need-based process
and ebay system
was the overall indebtedness of the
students once they left the gsb
because when you you're awarding aid in
a need-based system you're awarding it
to the neediest
students um and so you find that the
indebtedness overall
of the institution is driven down as
well so there's
those were the main reasons the main
principles of why we chose an ebay
system
and so obviously you know the it's our
new base system is going to be going to
the needs of students
um can you tell me more about kind of
like what are other opportunities
students use to
um to fund their mba uh while they're at
uh the gsb
yeah so um the i mean the main source
of funding that we offer is the
fellowship funding which is based on
that need-based system and fellowship
funding of course is free money that you
don't have to pay back right it's how we
distribute
our free money is through need the
average fellowship
is about forty thousand dollars per
academic year so for a two year program
the average is about eighty thousand
dollars
um that we're awarding to students uh
and then on you know
besides the the fellowship funding of
course there's loan funding and that's
part of financial aid as well that
there's loans and for
gsb students because we have a great um
us citizen base but also
international students we award there's
loan eligibility for not just our us
students
but also for international students so
those are the main sources of aid from
our office but there's also lots of
external aid that students bring with
them like
employer sponsorship or external
scholarships
or you know family members that want to
help support them that are giving them
gifts or
you know family loans so there's lots of
different ways to kind of create your
overall package or your overall
financial aid
um you know
that's great so i so let's just walk
through this so
i i am an admitted student i just got
into gsb
um i'm super excited uh and the first
thing i know i need to do is apply for
financial aid so
let's look walk me through the process
the timeline and just what happens
yeah so the key there is really that
you're applying for aid after you're
admitted
so there is no process before you're
admitted so once you're admitted
you receive the information from our
office to apply and we do
have a customized student financial aid
portal which you will access and it the
portal populates based on your
individual attributes like citizenship
or marital status and that's where you
submit
you know securely all this information
that we need uh to review your
your financial aid application to our
office and once we've done that once we
reviewed all your documentation then we
issue you the award letter
and so that that timeline is really
you you're admitted you apply for
financial aid and then we want to issue
you that award letter before you have to
accept your admissions offer
so you're making an informed decision
you have all the information you need up
front
to really understand what you're
committing to and then you can accept
your your financial you can accept your
admissions offer um
and then you know through your whole
life cycle what as a
matriculated student we will have you
reapply for financial aid or renew your
financial aid application
in your second academic year so we'll
work with you throughout you know your
entire
your gsb career and
and what is exactly the financial aid
looking at whenever they are
um assessing need for students yeah so
we're trying to assess your overall
financial aid situation or your overall
financial aid strength so
when you know most commonly what we're
going to ask for is some historic
information about your income
um and we look at two years of your your
financial aid income but
also with the need or your financial aid
or your financial income
in the past two years um with an ebay
system we also want to look at other
considerations that really
holistically give us an idea of your
financial situation because just looking
at two years of your
income doesn't always tell the whole
story
so we want to understand as well are you
supporting family members do you have
um you know medical expenses that we
need to be aware of so
we are looking at prior years income but
we're also looking at your current
situation and
and really your overall financial
situation
um and then additionally when we're new
this year which we're really excited to
um talk about uh is we are implementing
a new
uh bolt what we're calling the bold
fellowship and it's the building
opportunities for
leadership diversity fellowship and this
is an addition
to our need-based um fellowship
and so the biggest difference between
the bold fellowship and the need-based
uh fellowship is the bold really
assesses your your family's
financial need not just your individual
financial aid so it's one
step uh it's one step further to
understand the full financial picture
for you and your family and it's similar
to the need based process you apply once
you're admitted
and then will uh notify you for bold or
for the need-based fellowship
at the same time and
so what would happen if the financial
situation of a student changes
um in the you know it's a two-year
program what if something happens
changes in the middle of it that's
common
right i mean with a need-based system it
really is your
individual need and your financial
situation and we do
often see that it can change but from
the time that you're admitted
to sometimes in the middle of your
program and so
we we have avenues for you to report
this new information to us
because we do want to know when your
financial situation changes
so we can reassess your overall
financial strength
and you really we can do this at any
point when you're you're
a student at the gsb so there's there's
ways to report that information to us
and we encourage our students to do that
because it's
you know applying before your you accept
your admissions
offer doesn't mean you're in the same
financial situation once you've
matriculated so there's that open
channel of communication throughout your
entire program
that's great so you know a question that
i feel like we get a lot
um you know we have people in armed
services
from around the world um coming to gsb
um
and in particular in the us there are
programs like uh the gi bill yellow
ribbon
um could you walk through the for us in
the crowd
kind of what that means and uh what the
gsp does with that yeah so
the gsb is a yellow ribbon approved
school
um so this is chapter 33 with yellow
ribbon
and so our our benefit for our veteran
students uh us veteran students is it
covers
uh full tuition and mandatory fees of
the university
uh so essentially you're you're 100
covered for those
those items uh and then on top if you
have never accessed your yellow ribbon
before
in addition to um the payments that they
make towards your direct costs
uh the tuition and the fees you're also
eligible for a monthly housing stipend
uh from the va as well
so you're receiving a monthly stipend as
well as their pain and this the gsb is
committed to paying
um your those tuition fees in
conjunction with the va
and so you know i think there's a lot of
our students they
they're socially minded and after they
graduate they go into
a non-profit or they go to government
work
you know i think a lot of people are
interested in loan forgiveness programs
and in particular we have a strong one
here at the gsb
um that's kind of separate from some of
these national ones that we see
federally sponsored ones
uh can you tell us a little more about
exactly what the loan beginners program
looks like at the gsb
yeah yeah that's a great point because
for you know us citizens or if you've
had financially
before you may be aware that the
government the u.s department of
education
has their own loan forgiveness program
for non-profit work or public service
work
the gsb has a completely independent
loan forgiveness program that is
is ran by us it's our own funding uh
it's our own
you know program and it's it's we've had
it for
over 10 years it's a very well
established program and it helps
students who
decide go that they want to go into the
non-profit or public sector
um as a gsb alum typically those can be
lower income or lower salary
fields and so this loan forgiveness
program by the gsb
is to help you repay any educational
loan debt you acquire while you're here
and this could be for international
students this is for us
u.s students um and the great thing
about our program
is it's you can come in and out of it so
if you leave the gsb
and you decide you're going into the
private sector and then
you know down the road you realize that
you found your passion and nonprofit
as long as you have your educational
debt you can participate in this program
um so it's all it's always there and
what it does is it gives you
your essentially your monthly payment
plus your interest payment
um up front so you can pay back your
loans over
for a certain period of time and we have
our students apply for this program
every six months but it's a it's a
wonderful program we have a lot of
students who are utilizing it
uh and it's it we've had students who
successfully repaid their total
educational loan debt
just through this program you know if
you think that the nonprofit or the
public sector sectors where you want to
go
you can work internationally and access
this program so if you internationally
if you're going into an ngo
um there's you know you could qualify
for this program as well
and there's tons of information on our
public website about the program if
you're you're really interested in it
that's awesome so a lot of people who
are a good number of people who are
logged in right now
probably could have applied in round one
so they're eagerly awaiting decisions
that might that are going to be i think
about a month away at this point
so as that's getting closer liz what
would you recommend
uh some of those people start thinking
about uh right now
as the um you know admission might be
just like on horizon for them
yeah i mean it's this is a huge
financial commitment um
you know so understanding what the gsb
offers um up front going through that
information on the public website now is
really important
um one type of aid that i always i like
to
to really reinforce especially right now
even though you haven't even been
admitted
is external scholarships external
scholarships
um can tend to be very uh underutilized
you know at the gsb but also elsewhere
and that's because
the process to apply for an external
scholarship and this is really
any scholarship outside of the gsb
independent of our fellowship through
other organizations uh the process to
obtain
external scholarships can feel tedious
um
but the the cycles in which they award
external scholarships
for let's say next fall if you
matriculate next fall is right now these
scholarship
applications are open now so even though
you're not admitted this is the time
when you want to start
looking for external scholarships
because we do allow you to bring those
into the gsb to help supplement
you know any loans that you may need to
take or any other
contributions so we have some resources
right now on the public website we
actually have a list of external
scholarships that are available
that list is very specific to students
who have received
these memberships at our university so
don't limit yourself to that list use it
as a jumping off point that's where you
want to start
but definitely don't limit yourself to
it and start applying now like now's the
time to do it because once you're
admitted
and then you're thinking about it maybe
over the summer before you actually
matriculate at the gsb
those applications are already closed
for the upcoming academic year
so now is the perfect time to really
start exploring that
and then finally one thing that i talk
about a lot with students
is really budgeting and understanding
what the cost of attendance means
because the cost of attendance you can
find on our website
and for any institution really what a
cost of attendance is made up of
is direct and indirect costs and a
direct cost is something that the
university
will directly bill you for like tuition
like fees you know those things that you
have to pay
but the cost of attendance is also built
around indirect costs
and indirect costs are you know costs
that we
you know the we think that the student
may need to attend this university
and those costs may not be true to you
so really building a budget around what
you will need as a full-time student
and not just you know looking at the
cost of attendance and assuming that is
what i need
um is really really important to start
understanding now because you're going
to make
better informed decisions especially as
we consider
loan opportunities or other funding that
you made
you may need even if you're looking at
external resources now
um so that that budget what i really
need
is is really important
i think this is a great time also now
it's to look at some kind of questions
coming in from the people on the webinar
right now
yeah um and one that keeps popping up
here and i think would be great to chat
about
is you know we've talked a lot about our
need based
uh financial aid system and one of the
questions is are there any
merit-based scholarships for students
after they've already been admitted
after they've already matriculated
maybe based on grades are or
like how they participate in the
community yeah so
for the gsb we we only award need-based
um funding so we we don't have any merit
based fellowships um or any subsequent
fellowships that we award after the
the they've applied for financial aid so
really the need base is our primary
source of fellowship funding
there are other fellowship opportunities
at the gsb that are independent from our
office
um for example the knight hennessy
fellowship program is out there
but the application process is similar
to the application process
um for your admission so that you know
there's independent from our office
there are some other gsb resources but
our office is only awarding those
that need base aid that's great
and i i see we're kind of getting a
couple people in here um you know not
everyone who
uh enters uh nba program is necessarily
single
some people come with spouses and they
have children
so how do we factor that into our um
our decisions from uh awarding aid
yeah that's a great question because
what you see on the website when you're
when you're looking at
cost of attendance is we list a single
cost of attendance rate and then we list
a married cost of attendance rate
um so that you know your costs are much
different and even when you add children
into the mix
it can get a lot more expensive as well
um
so when we're look assessing your
overall financial need
we're we base your cost of attendance
which is part of our determination of
what you need
uh on your overall expense for the gsb
and if you're married we you know
there's greater expense for those
children so we are
considering um that there is a range of
expenses
based on your your situation are you
married are you bringing children
or do you have children that you're
supporting
great um another question we keep
getting
popping up is um does the gsb
offer full 100 uh financial aid coverage
uh or me need by a hundred percent
yeah so the no with the
with the need-based system um the you
know or awarding based on your
individual needs so
and when we talk about a hundred percent
there's lots of different ways to look
at it so it's important to understand
like
what 100 means to you so for
tuition and fees which are direct costs
or direct build costs of the university
there is a possibility you know based uh
based on your need that you can get
pretty close to that that total
expense but when you're looking at your
overall cost of attendance
that includes living expenses these kind
of indirect costs there's not a
fellowship specifically
that covers that that entire the
need-based fellowship that covers that
entire
um that entire amount you know programs
like the knight hennessy fellowship
which is independent of our office
there it that does cover closer to the
total cost of attendance but we do not
have a program specifically
um our need based program that covers
that total amount
that's wonderful um i got a couple
questions here too
um for people who are coming from maybe
another
master's program or they're coming from
their undergrad how are we assessing
uh their financial situation who maybe
are
unemployed or they're currently maybe on
another
fellowship with their other masters
program
yeah that's a great question i mean when
you when you apply for financial aid
we are looking at your current situation
but also what you're you're bringing you
know we're assessing your overall
financial strength what you're bringing
to the table
so the you know if you if we ask for two
years of income and you don't have two
years of income then that's
part of our understanding of your
overall financial situation
um so that you know that that specific
situation where you're an undergraduate
student or
you're in a master's program so you're
not working full-time is captured in our
analysis
okay and um i'm curious a lot of
questions we're gonna hear from people
um
if they you know when going through the
process um and they are supporting
family members outside of their spouse
or children
how is that factored into uh the uh the
need decisions
yeah that we ask for that information up
front when you're applying for financial
aid because it's important for us to
understand
not just you know what your historic
income might be
or what what you're bringing to the
table but where is that money going and
if you're supporting family members
we do give the opportunity for you to
explain that in your financial aid
application and it is part of our
understanding
of your overall ability to pay for the
program because if you're committed to
continuing
to support family members as a full-time
student
we want to make sure that we can factor
that in so
that is part of our understanding of
your complete holistic
picture you know your overall financial
picture and your overall financial
situation
and so we will ask for that information
up front and it is
part of our determination of your
eligibility
if a um if a student's admitted and you
know every year some things come up and
some students
uh have to defer for another year um
do they keep that same and they're
they're rewarded
need uh financially packaged does that
stay the same or is it going to be
reassessed the following year whenever
they actually matriculate
yeah that's a great question so you're
financial aid um
your financial aid application and what
we determine your eligibility is for
your specific class because we have one
pool of money for the cla your class
that you're admitted into
so if you decide to defer then
you're you would reapply for financial
aid
in the year that you're going to
matriculate into the program
so depending on the overall class and
the need of the class
your financial aid could be very similar
or it could be different it just totally
depends
so but there you will need to reapply
absolutely and i think we're getting a
couple questions about just
how the the loan process works okay um
so uh you know do whenever students a
lot of students take out the loans
um does the gsb offer any specific loans
and
uh what do we do when we're certifying
loans yeah so
the gsb is not a lender but we we do
help facilitate the process
so if you're a us citizen you generally
have two different loan buckets the
first one
is federal loans and the second one is
private loans and really how you decide
to finance your education is totally up
to you
sometimes we have students who just want
private loans sometimes we have students
who just want
um federal loans or sometimes we have a
mix and so the
and for international students we do
offer three different
private lenders that do not require a us
citizen for you to obtain a loan so you
have some options
um about who you want to lend with and
for the
the u.s citizens the loan process itself
just totally depends on which
lender you go with so if it's a federal
student loan
the there's two different types of
federal student loans that you could
potentially
access um one is the unsubsidized loan
and one is the graduate plus loan
and the combination of those two loans
together can help
finance your education and the the
interesting thing that we're seeing
especially this year
is that you know the the us department
of education actually sets
things like the loan interest rate and
the origination fee
and this year the the federal government
has set much lower interest rates than
we have seen before
at least i've seen in the last decade
they're going down which is really kind
of cool so you know you have
greater options between maybe accessing
the federal loans which
you know don't require um the the
interest rate's not based on your credit
it's essentially almost like an
entitlement program so you're eligible
for it
um or you can go with a private lender
and private lenders
the way that the loans work with a
private lender for international or for
us citizens
is it's based on your individual
application as far as the interest rate
your repayment term how long you want to
pay off the loan
if the lender itself has any origination
fees although we see with private
lenders they tend not to have
origination fees
um so there's lots of different options
and what we will do
um is point you to those lenders you
know the most common lenders at the gsb
for international students the three
lenders that we offer you
um and then you have the option to go
through the process with the lender to
understand what the the interest rate
may be or what your
you know what your can what you want in
a student loan
and then we will certify the loan once
you've selected the one that you want
and that's really
you know once we've certified that's how
they release disbursement to the
university so there's
lots of different ways that you can
approach how you lend and the great
thing the great conversations we
actually have with our students
is really around strategy lending
strategy
at what time during the academic year do
you need to borrow
at what amount do you actually need to
borrow and that goes back to those
indirect and direct costs
so there's lots of lots of different
ways to approach it but we're here to
walk you through that process
okay great um another great question i
saw come through
is how are the a student's
admissions decision and their need tied
are they taking into consideration
either way at the financial situation
it's not it's actually not tied at all
so the admissions process is completely
need blind
so you apply for financial aid after
you've been admitted
so there there's no correlation at all
it's completely independent which
you know really ties back to the
fairness um that we wanted to establish
with the need-based
program where everyone who's admitted
worked so hard to get admitted
should have the same opportunity for aid
and that comes after you've been
admitted into the program
great and we're getting here on time so
i am going to ask
one last question from the group um so
we've got someone here it looks like
they're a little farther out from
applying and they're asking what should
they start doing
to prepare financially uh for their mba
in the coming year before they apply
yeah i want to bring it back again to
the external
scholarships this is the time that you
want to start looking
and researching external opportunities
now
um that again that's one of the most
under utilized forms of financial aid
and the application cycles for external
scholarships
are always from the year prior so
students who may be matriculating fall
of 2021
should start applying for external
scholarships now
otherwise if you wait too long it will
close so those applications will close
so start looking into that now start
preparing those now if you can
great um well thank you everyone for
attending
uh liz thank you for answering all these
questions um
i hope they were all helpful for
everyone here um and please
if you have any other questions our
website is stocked full of information
check it out and maybe we'll be seeing
some of your faces on campus next year
okay bye everybody hi guys